I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense that the sexual harassment was I
brought my case July 6 2016 so what was
2015 like let's just go back to like
before that well
here's you been there since then what
year did you hear about about five my
Sundays three beds are a while yes yes
but the problem is because because of
the way in which we solve sexual
harassment cases in our society we
silence women through energies and
through settlements so I can't tell you
what it was like that's the unfortunate
consequence well then we should talk
about that because I um that I don't
want to get the ending forced
arbitration for sexual harassment is
that the actual case like if that's the
actual mission or is that just still
okay that's so so after after I filed my
lawsuit on July 6 2016 I had no idea
what was gonna happen I mean this was
the ultimate risk of my life and you
know the way I characterize it was
jumping off the cliff completely by
myself with no safety net below I had no
idea what to expect from one minute to
the to the next day to the next week and
I could have never known so many things
that happened like that they would start
an investigation Wow
you know on though on the whole
situation you know and that he my
perpetrator would be fired in two weeks
Wow I mean all the discussions with my
attorneys before were like oh they'll
try to save him you know nothing will
happen to him and everyone will malign
you for sure which did happen um so
there were a lot of things that turned
out for the positive that I could have
never predicted and then you know 15
months later the whole Harvey Weinstein
situation and the whole me - movement
exploded and then really the floodgates
opened at that point in time and we we
got into this whole Cultural Revolution
and I started working on trying to make
it better for women all across that
country almost immediately
as I started hearing from all of these
women almost immediately after I filed
my case and I realized then that this is
a pervasive epidemic I didn't know that
when I filed my case because when you do
something like this you're so alone and
you're made to feel like it's only
happening to you and what I came to find
out was that it crosses every
socio-economic line in every profession
so I was hearing from members of our
military police officers firefighters
teachers lawyers airline mechanics Wall
Street bankers of course other
journalists it was everywhere and the
scary thing was that almost all the
stories were eerily similar in the sense
that I finally found the courage to came
to come forward and I was promptly
blacklisted demoted and fired and the
majority of these women 99% of them that
reached out to me by the thousands have
never worked in their chosen profession
ever again and that's outrageous and
that's when I knew that I had to do
something to change it
[Music]